en vídeos pasados nos habíamos
preguntado cuál es la probabilidad de
obtener tres águilas en cinco volados en
este vídeo lo que quiero hacer es de
nuevo tomar una moneda justa aunque
veremos que es de esa condición la puedo
quitar más adelante tomar una moneda
justa y preguntarme cuál es la
probabilidad de obtener acá águilas en n
volados así que lo que quiero es la
probabilidad de obtener
exactamente
totalmente
de que aguilar es un número
águilas
aquí las
en volados donde calles son cualquier
número
claro que tiene que ser menor que en él
no tiene sentido que me pregunte por la
probabilidad de obtener 25 águilas en
dos volados ésta no tendría nada de
sentido pero bueno lo primero que voy a
hacer como antes es calcular cuál es el
número total de resultados posibles en
mis n volados así que digamos que este
es mi primer volado y mi primer volado
tiene dos posibilidades puede ser águila
o sol las dos igualmente probables
porque es una moneda justa el segundo
volado igual tiene sólo dos
posibilidades águila o sol el tercero
puede ser aguiló sol y así sucesivamente
hasta el enésimo volado así que aquí
tengo mis n volados y entonces tengo 2 x
2 x 2 x 2 x 2 n veces tengo 2 a la n
resultados posibles para mis n volados
muy bien pues ahora tengo que contar de
estos dos n resultados posibles cuáles
de ellos contienen exactamente que
águilas y del mismo modo que lo hicimos
antes en vez de pensar que las águilas
me van a salir lo que voy a imaginarme
es que yo controlo dónde salen las
águilas ok entonces tengo que acomodar
estas acá águilas en estos en el lugar
es cada volado representaría un lugar
entonces para la primera águila la puedo
colocar en cualquiera de los en lugares
disponibles así que tengo n
posibilidades para acomodarla para la
segunda águila como ya use una de las n
posibilidades sólo tengo en un lugares
disponibles para la tercera águila ya
usted dos así que tendría n menos 2 y
así sucesivamente hasta acomodar todas
mis gallinas de modo que este último
lugar sería n menos
-1 la razón por la que aquí aparece que
a menos uno en vez de acá es porque en
realidad estoy contando desde cero
fíjense aquí sería n 0 en menos 1 en
menos 2 de modo que si quiero que todo
esto de aquí sean
cada ghilas entonces tengo que llegar
hasta acá menos 1 porque empecé en cero
pero esto tiene un problema estoy
repitiendo eventos a qué me refiero con
eso imagínense que tengo águila a
águila ve y águila c entonces si las
acomodo de este modo es exactamente lo
mismo así las acomodo como águila de
águila y águila sé por qué a pesar de
que estas dos cosas tienen un orden
distinto las dos son instancias de que
me salga allí la águila águila no puede
distinguir al águila del águila be ok
entonces tengo que dividir entre todos
los modos posibles de reacomodar estas
águilas
imagínense que tengo objetos t1 t2
t3
así hasta teca
entonces de cuántos módulos por
reacomodar pues de uno lo puede poner en
cualquiera de cada lugar es que voy a
ocupar de dos lo puedo poner en
cualquiera de acá menos un lugar es
porque ya use un lugar para tf1 y así
sucesivamente el tercer objeto lo puedo
acomodar en cualquiera de los caminos
dos lugares que me quedan y así hasta
llegar a dos por uno
así que precisamente voy a dividir entre
por qué a menos uno
porque al menos dos
así hasta dos por uno
ok esto lo podemos checar cómo sigue
imagínense que aquí tuviera tres águilas
en cinco volados entonces este número
sería cinco por cuatro
por tres y ahí me detengo porque tengo
tres águilas entonces quiero llegar sólo
hasta cinco menos tres menos uno o sea
cinco menos dos que es tres y eso lo
dividiría entre los modos en los que
puedo reacomodar esos tres lugares es
decir tres por dos por uno
ok ahora bien hay algún modo hay algún
modo de reescribir por ejemplo esto de
un modo más sencillo y pues la respuesta
es que si lo hay y es en términos de lo
que se llaman factoriales para los que
ya sepan el factorial de un número que
está definido como el producto de k
porque a menos 1 porque a menos 2 así
hasta llegar a el 1 es decir el
factorial de un número simplemente es el
producto de todos los números que son
iguales son más chicos que el por
ejemplo 2 factorial es simplemente 2 por
13 factorial es igual a 3 por 2 por 14
factorial es igual a 4 por 3 por 2 por 1
y de hecho pueden seguir jugando con
estos los factoriales son números que
crecen muy muy rápido así que esto de
aquí por definición
es igual a k factorial ahora bien hay
algún modo de escribir lo que está
arriba de escribir el numerador de esta
fracción en términos de factoriales pues
veamos vamos a analizar un poco la
situación qué pasa si considero n
factorial en el factorial quien sería
pues sería m por n menos uno por n menos
así hasta el 1 pero en medio en algún
momento voy a llegar a el término nm a
menos 1
por n
por n - k
y así continuó hasta que ahora si llego
a dos por uno y la razón por la cual
escribí esto es porque qué pasa qué pasa
si yo aquí dividido entre m menos k
factorial
/ n que factorial entonces quién sería
eso
puedes y / también de este lado n
factorial sería n
por m - k menos 1 pero en el camino su
no es lo mismo que n - paréntesis camas
1 y así hasta llegar a 2 x 1 y entonces
fíjense qué pasa este n menos que
cancelaría a este n menos que éste n
menos camas 1 cancelar ya estã n menos
camas 1 y todos los números de abajo
irían cancelando a los números de arriba
hasta hasta quedarme sólo con esta parte
de aquí sólo con esto que es
precisamente lo que tenía arriba esto de
aquí es idéntico a este numerador
si no me creen podríamos checarlo
rápidamente si vuelvo a poner en igual a
5 y acá igual a 3 entonces que sería ese
número sería 5 factorial entre
5 - 3 factorial que es 2 factorial y
esto sería 5 por 4 por 3 por 2 por 1
dividido entre 2 factorial que sería 2
por 1
este 2 cancelar este 2 este 1 cancelar
este 1 aunque realmente son unos
entonces no importa y me queda 5 por 4
por 3 que es precisamente lo que me
había quedado en el numerador en el
ejemplo que diría anteriormente así que
bien en resumen siempre que tengan cada
objeto si los quieran acomodar en n
lugares posibles entonces esta fórmula
se va a aplicar esta fórmula de aquí
primero vamos a tomar este número
este número que ya vimos que era n
factorial entre n factorial voy a tomar
en el factorial
entre n factorial
en el cap perdón factorial y lo voy a
dividir entre este número entre k
factorial así que aquí todavía tengo que
dividir entre k factorial
y este número de aquí se llama el
coeficiente binomial y a veces se denota
así quiero encontrar la forma de
acomodar acá objetos en en lugares a
veces se escribe así y se puede leer
como las combinaciones de n en k o
también lo podría pensar en que tengo n
cosas y quiero seleccionar sin
importarme el orden que de ellas tengo n
cosas idénticas y quiero seleccionar
cada de ellas también se puede escribir
así y como les decía esto se llama el
coeficiente binomial bien pues
regresando a nuestro problema original
que era de encontrar la probabilidad de
exactamente cada ghilas en n volados
pues ya sabemos que el número total de
resultados es 2 a la n 2 a la n
resultados posibles en n volados
entonces la probabilidad en el estribo
por aquí
probabilidad
ya no voy a escribir qué es lo que
estamos buscando pero la probabilidad
siempre es igual a el número de eventos
favorables entre el número de eventos
posibles el número total de eventos que
ya sabemos es 2 a la n iv cuáles son los
eventos favorables son aquellos que
exactamente contienen en este caso que
águilas son los que satisfacen mi
condición de aquí entonces
cuál es ese número pues lo que vamos a
encontrar es este número de aquí
este número de aquí entonces ese número
va a ser n factorial / k factorial por n
- k factorial o si lo quiero escribir de
un modo quizás más bonito lo podría
escribir como n en k las combinaciones
de enka por 1 entre 2 a la n iv bueno
quizás sea buena idea que se aprendan
esta fórmula a mí me gusta re derivar la
cada vez que la voy a usar para
asegurarme de entenderlo todo bien me
entretiene pensar en que tengo mis
objetos y los quiero acomodar en el
lugares disponibles entonces este sería
el número de formas de hacerlo pero
luego tengo que vivir entre la cantidad
de modos en los que podría reacomodar
esos objetos y por eso me gusta volver a
re derivar esto todas las veces que lo
utilizo